three two the date was January 19th 2006
Cape Canaveral Florida a spacecraft the
size of a grand piano left earth on top
of a rocket traveling 36,000 miles per
hour this is New Horizons it's a NASA
probe and its mission is to complete our
initial tour of the solar system by
flying past Pluto and its moons onboard
our seven scientific instruments a
generator fueled by decaying plutonium
and a few other things
it has a container filled with the ashes
of Clyde Tombaugh that's the astronomer
who discovered Pluto back in 1930 it has
two American flags to state quarters
from Florida and Maryland a cd-rom
filled with the names of 400,000 people
who signed up back in 2005 a cd-rom with
pictures of the new horizons team a
piece of spaceship one that's the first
privately owned spacecraft and the US
stamp from 1991 that says Pluto not yet
explored so New Horizons has been flying
for more than nine years now and its
date with Pluto has finally arrived
[Music]
to understand how big this is you have
to get that Pluto is really far away
it's really really far away billions of
miles away so back in grade school when
we modeled the solar system it kind of
looked like this but actually this is a
huge lie okay so if Earth were the size
of a basketball Pluto would be the size
of a golf ball and at that same scale
the distance between them okay tell me
when to stop keep going keep going
okay now go outside get on a train
wait what the golf ball would be over 50
miles away holy yeah and then said its
closest distance from us and at the same
scale New Horizons NASA's robot would be
a tiny fraction of the size of a grain
of sand and despite this immense
distance NASA's engineers have
successfully guided New Horizons toward
its target and they're retrieving data
back over radio waves very slowly the
radio waves take four-and-a-half hours
to come all the way from New Horizons to
us NASA has to use 200 foot wide
antennas just to even detect a signal
and the download speed is one kilobit
per second so one kilobit per second how
slow is that exactly so if you had a you
got an image that's 1024 pixels wide it
would take about 40 minutes just to
download it that's 50 times slower than
your dial-up modem for the 90s and one
of the key pieces of data that New
Horizons will be retrieving is good
photos of Pluto right now we don't have
any good photos of Pluto the best things
we have from the Hubble Space Telescope
it still looks like a blurry blob but
New Horizons is gonna return historic
high-definition photos of Pluto it
already got some great shots of Jupiter
when it flew by in 2007 to use the giant
planets gravity as a slingshot
so right now New Horizons is traveling
at over 31,000 miles per hour and it's
pretty much used up all its fuel so it
can't slow down as it approaches the
target so all these observations are
gonna be happening really quickly
after that after that New Horizons just
gonna keep going then in 2019 and here's
are gonna fly it past another small icy
object at the edge of the solar system
to collect more data and as for Pluto
it'll continue on around the Sun taking
248 years to complete one revolution so
that means the entire history of the
United States has unfolded in the time
it's taken Fudo to orbit the Sun once
the last time Pluto was in his current
position we didn't understand how
species evolved or how germs transmitted
diseases Wow aviation was still decades
away and spaceflight wouldn't happen for
nearly 200 years but this time around
when Pluto finishes its orbit it's going
to be met by a tiny robot sent by a
curious species of apes living on a
planet billions of miles away
[Music]